[موسيقى]
الانترنت بات عاملا مركزيا في اداره شؤون
الحياه ولم يعد مجرد اداه تواصل بين البشر
ونقل للمعلومات والبيانات بينهم عبر
الهاتف المحمول او حاسوب فما تطور الهائل
في تقنيات الاتصال والذكاء الاصطناعي
ومعداته المزوده بمستشعرات البرمجيات صار
ممكنا ربط الاجهزه عبر الانترنت وتبادل
البيانات بينها والتحكم فيها عن بعد انت
ممكن تتعرف على محتويات الثلاجه المنزليه
مثلا عن بعد من خلال الاتصال عبر الانترنت
وكذا تشغيل السياره والتحكم فيها عبر
الحاسوب فيما يعرف بانتنه الاشياء ويقدر
عدد الاجهزه التي تستخدم هذه التقنيات
بالمليارات ومع تطور المستمر امتد استخدام
هذه التقنيات الى مجال الرعايه الصحيه
لمراقبه المرضى في منازلهم وصرف الادويه
لهم من الصيدليات الذكيه ويتوقع خبراء ان
تصل الى قيمه سوقي انت اشياء في رعايه
الصحيه الى قرابه 500 مليار دولار خلال ست
سنوات وبات الانسان نفسه هدفا لما توصفه
بتقنيات انترنت الاجسام وتوفرت اجهزه
متصله بالانترنت يمكن لصقها على الجلد او
زراعتها الداخله الثامنه تراقب اداء الجسم
البشري وحركته ولياقته البدنيه ضربات قلبه
ضغط دمه والتنبؤ بما قد يعتريه من ازمه
صحيحه في قصتنا الليله ان كانت الاجسام
نتناولها هذا التطور التكنولوجي وامكانات
لمرضى استفادوا من تقنياته في تحسين ظروف
حياتهام وما يوفرهم الفرس للملايين في
العالم كما نتناوله ما يحمله من محاضره
ومخاطر على حياه المستخدمها وحمايه
بياناتهم الصحيه من التحكم او التلاعب من
المؤسسات شركات الكبرى المتحكمه في هذه
التكنولوجيا
نفسك منه بقيه القصه مع الدكتور وائل عبد
المجيد والسبب ذكاء الاصطناعي مؤسس مختبر
الذكاء البصري وتحليل الوسائط المتعدده
بجامعه جنوب كاليفورنيا والدكتور وائل فهد
الحسين اخصائي امراض القلب والشرايين
والاستاذ بجامعه المحاضر في طب الكوارث
بجامعه نسال ضيفين عن مدى تطور الراهن في
مجال اجهزه وتقنيات انترنت الاجسام
والمتوقع له المستقبل وهل بدنا نقترب من
عالم تتحكموا في البشر اليات وتطبيقات
وتقنيات للذكاء الى الصناعيه وعن امكانيه
وضع قوانين او ضوابط تنظم عمل هذه
التقنيات وتعظم اجابتها لكن نشاهد القصه
اولا ثم نبدا بالحوار
جيو فودافون
[موسيقى]
قبل نصف القرن شهد العالم ارسال اول بريد
الكتروني على يد المبرمج الامريكي ريمون
توميانسون كانت البشريه قد عرفت نقل
البيانات الرقميه عبر خطوط الهاتف للمره
الاولى اواخر خمسينيات القرن الماضي والذي
كان اساسا مبكرا لواحد من اهم الاختراعات
التي عرفتها البشريه الانترنت والذي بات
عاملا مركزيا في اداره شؤون الحياه في
البدايه كان الانترنت من اهم الادوات التي
اخترعها الانسان في العصر الحديث فصارت
تتوسع سلطه الانترنت حتى صار الانسان
موضعا للانترنت ومفعولا للانترنت
فتحها مجموعه من الطلاب بجامعه في ولايه
بنسلفانيا الامريكيه اعيون العالم على
مسار جديد عندما نجحوا في ربط ماكينه
المشروبات في طرقات الجامعه بالشبكه
الداخليه ليستطيع الطلاب من مكانهم معرفه
مدى المشروبات المثلجه بها ما كان اذانا
بميلاد ما بات يعرف بانترنت الاشياء تطور
الامر فاجات الانسان التواصل مع الاله عبر
الانترنت يتحكم بها ويصدر لها الاوامر
ويستقبل منها المعلومات فسرنا نشهد كل يوم
اضافه صفه الذكاء لواحده من الالات عبر
ربطها بالانترنت فاصبحت لدينا المباني
الذكيه والسيارات الذكيه بل وحتى المبردات
والمقاعد والمراحيض الذكيه
الاشياء على جميع الاجهزه المتصله
بالانترنت مثل سيارتك وهاتفك وجهازي
تلفازك والتي يمكنها ارسال استقبال
البيانات عبر الانترنت قادتنا تلك
التكنولوجيا الى النباتات يعرف بانترنت
الاجسام حيث اصبح لدينا اجهزه متصله
بالانترنت يمكن تثبيتها على الجلد او حتى
تتم زراعتها داخل اجسامنا
امتد الطموح والتجريب في مجال انترنت
الاشياء الى جسد الانسان ذاته تحول معه
هذا الجسد الى منصه الانطلاق مئات الاجهزه
والتطبيقات ليكون العالم على موعد مع
تكنولوجيا جديده باتت تعرف باسم انترنت
الاجسام كان المجال الطبي على راس
القطاعات التي وظفت تلك التكنولوجيا
كمضخات الانسولين واجهزه رصد النبات
بالاضافه الى دعامات القلب الذكيه وجهازي
تنظيم ضربات القلب والاطراف الاصطناعيه
الذكيه وجهاز قوقعه الاذن لضعاف السمع
والحبوب الرقميه القابله للهضم وغيرها من
الاجهزه الطبيه المتطوره سواء المعالجه
منها او المراقبه للاجسام والقادره على
التنبؤ بمشاكلها الصحيه التي قد تقع في
المستقبل
في الولايات المتحده التقينا ماريلي
الباحثه بمؤسسه التطوير والابحاث
الامريكيه ترامب والتي نشرت ورقه بحثيه
حملت عنوان انترنت الاجسام الفرص المخاطر
الحوكمه
الاجسام الى مجموعتين الاولى تضم الاجهزه
الطبيه المجموعه الاخرى هي الاجهزه
الاستهلاكيه غير الطبيه
قد يكون منقذ للحياه انه الانسان بسبب
وجود هذا المنظم ينقذ حياته وعلاج الامراض
الى اخره فوائدها كثيره في فوائد مباشره
وهامه جدا لدرجه انها تنقذ حياه الانسان
وفي فوائد همم نفسيه تعطي الانسان بانه
جزء من هذا العالم الحديث
انترنت الاجسام على انه نظام متكامل يجمع
بين الاجهزه من الناحيه وبينما تجمعه تلك
الاجهزه من بيانات من ناحيه اخرى لذلك يجب
ان تبقى متصله بالانترنت اما بشكل مباشر
او غير مباشر وانت تمتع بقدرات حاسوبيه او
برمجيه هذه الاجهزه يمكنها جمع البيانات
الحيويه الشخصيه للمستخدم او القيام ببعض
وظائف الجسم شده من باريس فاشن
في البدايه
اعراض ما كانت موجوده عندها من قبل الشعور
والاحساس انها فاقده المايك طبعا النحول
همم تكون دائما هزيله فحسيت ان هذا شيء مو
طبيعي فبعدين
مريضه بسكري من النوع الاول طبعا الدكتور
المشرف على علاج طبعا نصحنا في جهاز جديد
موجود هو عباره عن انسولين بام هو عباره
عن يحسب نسبه السكر وعلى حسب نسبه السكر
والاكل اللي اكلتها يضيف نسبه الانسولين
فطبعا كان همم اعجاز بالنسبه لنا عدد
فحص السكر اتوقع ايه بعد ارتاح حبيبتي انه
صارت شوي اهدى صارت قبل الالم صار اقل
الانسولين
من الخارج حيث يعمل باستمرار على ايصال
الانسولين الى الجسم في الواقع خلال
الاعوام الماضيه اصبح لعلاجه
اكثر ارتباطا بمستشارات قياس مستوى
الجلوكوز في الدم فالمستشعر يتصل بالمضخه
عبر خوارزميه تساعدها على التحكم في جرعات
الانسولين التي تضخها في الجسم بشكل الي
وخاصه بين الوجبات بناء على مستويات
الجلوكوز في الدم والتي تتعرف عليها
المضخه من خلال المستشعرات يتم التوصيل
الانسولين عبر خوارزميه الدقيقه لذلك اذا
ارتفعت مستويات لجلوكوز فان المضخه تعطي
المزيد من جرعات الانسولين واذا كانت
مستويات الجلوكوز في طريقها الى المستوى
الطبيعي او حتى على اعتاب نوبه هبوط لتتن
مستوى السكر في الدم فيمكن للمضخه تعليقه
او تقليله كميه الانسولين يحدث هذا كل خمس
دقائق كل هذا يعني اننا نتقلنا الى حقبه
جديده في السنوات الخمس الماضيه في مستوى
ما نقدمه
لما صار المريض غير قادر على انه يجيء
اشوفه انا اشوف قراءات السكر عنده
فبالتالي وجود الري او قراءات الطفل على
الانترنت ساعدنا كثير بالنسبه للمرضى وما
زالوا احنا بنتلقى يوميا مسجات من الاهالي
انه فيك تشوفي قراءاتي انا السكر ارتفع
عندي امبارح اليوم السكر عندي نزل بروح
بشوف كل شيء بشوف متى هو اعطى انسولين مثل
مضخه اعطته حتى الانمي الي اعطته اياها
المضخه فبالتالي هو صح لي كثير على المرضى
وعلينا كمقدمين دعايه صحيه غير انه انت
لما بتشوف الطفل بتشوف الطفل لما بيجيك
فيسبوك انت ممكن فيك تشوف كل يوم سبع
اطفال لكن لما عم تتواصل معهم على
الموبايل او على الانترنت
[موسيقى]
فقد امتد ذلك التطور للمجال الرياضي اللي
يشهدوا العالم كل يوم ظهور مستشعرات
واجهزه مختلفه المهام ترتبط باجساد
الرياضيين يرى مبتكروها انها قادره على
تحسين وتطوير ممارسه الرياضه ومضاعفت
نتائجها
[موسيقى]
طبعا كالرياضي محترف كان دائما بواكب
والمنتجات الرياضيه وخاصه منتجات الذكيه
همم الموضوع منتشر من اربعه خمس سنين يمكن
اكثر من هيك بدي مع الساعات الذكيه
وتطور بعدين ليكون ادوات مخصصه لاداء
الرياضي
لفات انتباهي باللباس الرياضي الذكي انه
هو عباره عن كنزه فانت بتلبسها وبتكون
محلها دقيقه وبتعمل تمرين الابلكيشن
هيسالك كذا السؤال الاول ما تنزله اه شو
عمرك همم شو طولك شو وزنك اه شو جنسك شو
هدفك من التمرين طبعا المعلومات هاي
الابليكيشن كلها بياخذها وبخزنها على
معلومات على معادلات رياضيه لحتى يستخدمها
خلال التموين طبعا لما بياخذ معلومات كلها
هاي وبدخلها على الجهاز
ببلش هو حسب دقات قلبك
اه شو بحتاج مثلا بقول لك انه ادائك ضعيف
او انت اه جسمك داخل الاكسجين في ضعيف في
ميزه اه ثالثه
بعلمك كيف تاخذ نفس على همم وقت منيح اللي
هو مثلا في خمس دقائق همم
مرتبط بموضوع الاكسجين عم بدخلها جسمك
سيلون واسع من الابتكارات ومنتجات
وتطبيقات تضاف كل يوم الى عالم انترنت
الاجسام تطفي مزيدا من الرفاهيه على حياه
مستخدميها فهناك اجهزه رصد الانتباه وهي
نظارات تستخدم نشاط الدماغ وحركات العين
لتتبع مستويات التركيز وهناك اجهزه
الاستشعار المزروعه تحت الجلد والاحذيه
الذاتيه الربط واجهزه تتبع اللياقه
البدنيه والوشم الالكترونيه وعادسات
الواقع المعزز كما ان هناك حفاضات الاطفال
التي تكشف عن حركات الامعاء وتبلغ عنها
وبعض الحلي كالاساور والخواتم المزروع
بداخلها رقائق قادره على قياس بعض الوظائف
الحيويه وجميعها يمكن متابعه معلوماته عبر
تطبيقاتها الهاتفيه
حساسات متابعه الاطفال سمعت عنها من وقت
قريب لما كنت حامل بعد كده عرفت انه
الموضوع اثار انتبهنا ففكرنا نحن ممكن
نعمل حاجه زي كده ونجربها مع البيبي
بتاعنا
نبضات القلب
قعدت على الجهاز يومين كاملين
جهاز القلب القلب البيبي فا حاجه زي دي
هتبقى مهمه ان انت تتابعها
انا بحث عن الحساسات بتاعه الاطفال وبعد
كده همم بدانا شوفنا كذا نوع منها همم
الساعه وشفنا كمان الشرابات فلقينا المشبك
دوت هيكون انسب حاجه للبيبي تبقى متوصله
على طول وتكون انسب في التعامل مع الطفل
يعني فكره انك تكون مسؤوله عن مخلوق ضعيف
ما يقدرش ان هو يعبر عن نفسه دي كانت فكره
اا مرعبه جدا يعني في الحقيقه سنسر دوت
خلاني احس ان ممكن اتعامل مع البيبي بشكل
همم سلس اكثر وسهل واقدر ان انا همم اسمعه
واتجاوب معه بسهوله يعني السنسور هو اهم
جزء في الجهاز بالنسبه لي وباقدر بسهوله
اشبكوا في هدوم البيبي بحيث ان الجزء
السفلي يكون ملامس للجلد البيبي علشان
يقدر ياخذ القرايات من خلال السنسور ده في
الحقيقه انا بدات اسمع الاول مره عن
الانترنت الاجسام من مميزاتها ان هي لو
انت بعيد عن طفله فهي ممكن تنبهك انه طفلك
بي بيعيط
بيتحرك اا او لقدر الله مثلا حصل ان هو
اختنق وهو نايم فيكون عندك همم ضربات قلبه
او تنفسه بكل الحاجات دي بتظهر على
الابلكيشن او بيبعت لك بيها تنبيهات يعني
انترنت الارسام يثار الحديث عن ما توفره
تلك تكنولوجيا من بيانات ومعلومات تمس صحه
الناس وحياتهم وما قد يصاحب ذلك من قرصنه
لتلك المعلومات او توظيف تجاري لها فضلا
عن ذلك فان الارتباط المباشر لتلك الاجهزه
بابساد مستخدمها يطرح تساؤلات حول ما قد
يستر عنها من موجات واثر ذلك على صحه
مستخدميها اضافه الى مخاطر اعتراض موجاتها
او التحكم بها عن بعد
نحن نتحدث عن اجسام بشريه وبالتالي
المخاطر تكون حياه او موت في هذه الحال
حيث ان هذه الاجهزه التي تتصل باجسام
البشر تقوم بمراقبه همم اعضاء حيويه في
جسم الانسان مما قد يودي بحياه هذا
الانسان اذا ما حدث اي خلل او اضطراب في
استخدامها او حتى في صحه البيانات التي
تقوم بنقلها فهناك مخاطر لا يمكن تجاهلها
كيف
يمكن الشام في اعتقادي يعتمد ذلك
للك
يان لتلك البيانات سواء كان صانع الجهاز
او مستخدمه او المستشفى الذي يحتوي على
بياناتك الطبيه اعتقد ان امنه تلك
المعلومات يعتمد بشكل كبير على هذه
الكيانات خافي من وجود المعلومات في
الانترنت او من خلال همم
لا ما عندي تخوف كون هذه الدراسه راح تفيد
بنتي همم اتوقع فيه لجان وفي مؤسسات همم
مسؤوله ويكون في عقود بينهم وبين المؤسسات
وبينهم وفي موافقات واجرينت انه هل ادتها
هذه تؤخذ
ويدرس عليها للابحاث للاستفاده منها
مصابين السكري بالعكس هذا شيء يفيدنا فليش
لا يعني هذا شيء ما يخوفني اهم شيء انهم
ما يوصلون او يؤثرون في علاج بنتي
حلو وشوي مخيف نفس الوقت انه المعلومات
هيك كلها بتخزن عليها بياناتك
ومعلوماتك الشخصيه لو حتى تطلب منه موقعك
برا ممكن اكيد ياخذ او يستخدموها ولكن اه
ما بعرف لاي درجه كون انت بالاخير عم تنشر
شيء عن جسمك عن نفسك ان هناك الكثير من
المخاطر المحتمله لاستخدام تلك الاجهزه
ليست على المستوى الشخصي فحسب بل على
مستوى الامن القومي ففي واقعه شهيره
استبدل نائب الرئيس الامريكي الاسبق
لكتشيني جهاز تنظيم ضربات القلب المزروعه
بجسده لاخر لا يمكنه الدخول على شبكه
الانترنت لتامينه من التعرض لعمليه اغتيال
عن بعد كل حاجه موجوده على الانترنت انه
معلومات طفله
والحاجات دي كلها بتوصل معلوماتك كل
الجهات وده شيء خلاص ما بقاش في مفر منه
لانها متعدده الجنسيات وعابره للحدود
الجغرافيه وكذا فانا في رايي انه هذه
الشركات لابد ان تخضع همم معايير اخلاقيات
حتى وان يصنعوها هم بانفسهم لكن يخبرونا
ما المعايير اييي ويعلم الناس هذه
المعايير يقبلها من يقبلها يرفضها من
يرفضها للاسف لا توجد تشريعات او قوانين
صريحه في عالمنا العربي تخص انترنت
الاجسام ولكنها تشريعات تخص الانترنت بشكل
عام هذه القوانين فضفاضه تاتي بصوره مجمله
غير دقيقه مما يسمح في اساءه استخدام هذا
النوع من التكنولوجيا احيانا في الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه مثلا هنا قوانين تضبط
استخدام وترخيص اجهزه الانترنت واجهزه
الانترنت الاجسام وما تتحصل عليه من
معلومات
البلد الذي تعيش فيه فمثلا نجد ان بعض
الولايات الامريكيه لديها قوانين خاصه
تختلف عن الولايات الاخرى وبالتالي فان
الامر يعتمد حقا على موقعك والجهاز الذي
تتحدث عنه اشياء من هذا القبيل
لكن ترى ما هو واقع انتشار تطبيقات انترنت
الاجسام في عالمنا العربي والى اي مدن
اصبح الناس اكثر قبولا لوجود اجهزه تلتصق
باجسامهم
لا يمكنني تاكيد شيوعي هذه الاجهزه في
العالم العربي على وجه التحديد لكنني
اعتقد انها تشبه الى حد ما كيفيه انتشار
الهواتف الذكيه في كل مكان الان لن
يفاجئني ان ارى اجهزه انترنت الاجسام
اصبحت شائعه في جميع انحاء العالم
في النمو في العالم العربي في السنوات
الاخيره خصوصا وهو ما يمكن ان الحظه
بسهوله من حولنا في المستشفيات او الانديه
الرياضيه او حتى داخل البيوت في الاجهزه
الاستهلاكيه والترفيه للبالغين والاطفال
على حد سواء حيث من المتوقع ان يصل عدد
الاجهزه القابله للارتداء المتصله
بالانترنت في الشرق الاوسط وافريقيا والتي
من ضمنها علمنا العربي الى و40 مليون جهاز
بنهايه العامل 2022 بينما وصل الحجم السوق
الاجهزه الطبيه القابله للارتداء والتي
يطلق عليها الورى والميدكل ديفايسيز الى
ما يزيد عن 389 مليون دولار في 2022
ومتوقع ان تقترب من الملياردولار في العام
2027 بين مشجع يرى في انترنت الاجسام نقله
تكنولوجيه كبيره تطفي على حياه البشر صحه
ورفاهيه وقدرات خاصه وبين حذر لا ينكر
قيمتها لكنه يرى في الوقت ذاته مخاطرها
وتحدياتها يزداد انتشار تطبيقات انترنت
الاجسام وكانها واقع يفرض نفسه بينما ترسم
طموحات وتطلعات البشر مستقبله
نرحبوا بكم مجددا المشاهدين الكرام
وبضيفينا الكريمين مدينتي بيتبول وائل عبد
المجيد وهو استاذ الذكاء الاصطناعي مؤسس
مختبر الذكاء البصري وتحليل الوسائط
المتعدده بجامعه جنوب كاليفورنيا ومن
بوسطن الدكتور وائل فهد الحسيني الاخصائي
في امراض القلب والشرايين والاستاذ بجامعه
اهلا بضيفين الكريمين موضوع مهم جدا
في الواقع ومثير للمشاهد نحاول قدر
الامكان تبسيط المعلومات حتى تصل لاكبر
قدر ممكن من المشاهدين ابدا معك دكتور
وائل عبد المجيد يعني ما الذي يمثله في
الواقع هذا تطور
التكنولوجيا والعلمي في حياتنا من
الانترنت الاشياء الى ان كانت الاجسام وهل
من رابط بين الاثنين
شكرا على الاستضافه هو الحقيقه الاثنين
نفس الشيء انترنت الاشياء وانترنت الاجسام
نفس الشيء هي مجرد الجهاز او ديفايس
مرتبطه بالانترنت بتجمع بيانات طول الوقت
وبتبعت البيانات دي
الجريفم او اللوغاريتميه معينه
بتعمل قرار معين او بتعمل بريدكشن معين هل
نقدر نزود الانسولين او لا او حاجه زي كده
ههه المشكله الحقيقه تفضل نعم لكن الفرق
بين الاثنين على حسب ما فهمنا نحن
بمعلوماتنا البسيطه هو ان ااه الانترنت
الاشياء هو منفصل لكن الانترنت الاجسام قد
يكون بجلد الانسان مرتبط به اليس كذلك وما
الذي يمثل ذلك في نهايه الامر هذا الموضوع
مضبوط هو الاثنين الحقيقه زي ما حضرتك
قولتي هو انترنت الاجسام عباره عن دبي
اللي هي الانسان يقدر يرتديها زي الساعه
او تقدر تبقى جوه الجسم زي مثلا منظم
ضربات القلب في نهايه الامر ال ال ال ال
الديفايسز دي بتعمل بتجمع بيانات وبتبعتها
اللوغاريتمات معينه بحيث انها تعمل قرارات
تساعد في تنظيم ضربات القلب او تساعد في
جرعات الانسولين همم على سبيل المثالي
اتمنى الدكتور
اخصائيين ما الذي حمله لكم هذا التطور
التكنولوجي الهائل
مساء الخير شكرا على هذه الاستضافه
يعني بصراحه الان لا نستطيع ان نعيش دون
هذه الاجهزه لقد ساهمت هذه الاجهزه بشكل
كبير وفرت الانقطاع الطبي سرعه التشخيص
دقه التشخيص التقليل من الاخطاء الطبيه
زياده المعرفه هم من خلال المساحه وجمع
المعلومات بالاضافه ساهمت بشكل كبير
لانقاذ حياه المرضى
وقد اعطيك مثال على ذلك يعني جهاز
الدفريتر من جهاز صاعق الكهربائي هذا همم
يعني يعطى لمرضى اللي عندهم اضطرابات في
القلب تحتاج الى ضربه كهربائيه قبل ذلك
كان يسبب وفيات اذا لم يتوفر هذا الجهاز
المريض هذا الجهاز مرتبط في في عباره عن
الواير اللي هو سلك داخل القلب ويعطي ال-
الصعق الكهربائي نفس الجهاز في همم يجمع
بيانات عن همم المريض ويرسل هذه البيانات
بشكل مستمر الى المستشف
فنستطيع بشكل مباشر معرفه اذا ما تعرض
المريض الى الخطا ونحن عندنا في الاوفيس
واحيانا اذا كانت الصاعقه الكهربائيه اجت
لمريض كاد ان يتوفى همم يعني يصدر عنا صوت
في الجهاز او اا نتفكيشن للجهاز الطبي
فلابد انه نركز على
ايجابيات التي ساهمت في رغم انه هنالك
قليل من همم التحضيرات لكن اجمالا سلبيا
لكن اجمالا ساهمت بشكل كبير في التسارع
همم
يعني كيف يتم تقييم الفوائد الصحيه لهذه
الاجهزه ما هي الاسس المعتمده ربما في
اجازه هذا الجهاز واعطاء الضوء الاخضر
تعبير بان هذا الجهاز امن ويمكن الاعتماد
عليه بطريقه همم يعني همم شفافه وبدون ايه
سلبيات هل يتم الموضوع عبر مراحل ام ماذا
نعم يعني
كمثال خليني ارجع نفس الجهاز هو يعطي
صاعقه كهربائيه قبل هذا الجهاز ااا لابد
ان همم نشوف المريض نفسه في غرفه الطوارئ
وعنده هاي المشكله حدثت ونعطيه كهربائيه
حقيقيه في جهاز كبير من دون الاعتماد على
التكنولوجيا فتبدا هي في مراحل تبدا كفكره
الان كيف نطور هذه الفكره لجهازي يحمل
المريض وياخذه معه همم فبدات الشركات في
تطوير هذه الفكره بدات في مراحل طويله ومن
ثم بعد ذلك اثبت التجربه الغير سريريه
بنجاح ثم دخلت يعني تدخل الى الامريكيه
للغذاء والدواء الامريكيه في مراحل
ودراستها ودراست فعاليتها ومحدرها ومن ثم
تبدا المرحله السريديه والتجارب على
المرضى الذين يقبلون ان تجرب عليهم هذه
الاجهزه وبعد ذلك بعد اثبات انها همم امنه
وفعاله
الشركات بتصنيعها وارسالها للمستشفيات
وزراعتها بشكل طويله يعني
تحت التجربه وتاخذها لعده تجارب حتى يتم
اعتمادها بشكل كامل اعد للدكتور وائل عبد
المجيد الدكتور وائل سمعت المثال الذي
ذكره الدكتور
وائل الحسامي عن جهاز الصاعق الكهربائي في
فيلمنا الليل يتحدثنا عن عده تقنيات
تحدثنا مضخه الانسولين اجهزه رصد النوابات
منظم ضربات القلب دعامات القلب الذكيه
الاطراف الصناعيه الذكيه الحبوب الرقميه
القابله الهضم الهضم وغيرها نتساء الحقيقه
الى اين تذهب بين هذه التكنولوجيا يعني ما
الجديد في هذا المجال والى اين وصلت ربما
تطبيقات الرعايه الصحيه والطبيه من ناحيه
التطور
هو الحقيقه الامل في المستقبل في استخدام
الاجهزه دي هو ما يسمى بالبرسجن ميدسن او
الطب الدقيق اللي هو معظم الادويه دلوقتي
او العلاجات مبنيه على فكره
متوسط الحالات الاجهزه اللي زي الانترنت
وفي باديس دي او انترنت الاجسام بتدينا
فرصه ان ان الدواء او جرعه الانسولين او
المنظم ضربات القلب يبقى مخصص لشخص معين
بدل ما يبقى معمول بشكل عام لعموم الناس
ففكره البرسجن هي دي اعتقد المستقبل في
تطبيقات انترنت الاجسام
ما ابرز التحديات التي تواجهها تطوير
التكنولوجيا انترنت الاجسام والاشياء وحتى
استخداماتها باعتقادك
والله هو في اكثر من تحدي زي ما حضرتك
قلتي في التقرير سابقا فكره الهاكرز او
فكره حد ممكن يخترق منظم ضربات قلب زي ما
حصل مثلا مع ديكشني او كانديكشنري
ففكره اختراق الاجهزه دي فكره خصوصيه
المعلومات لان الاجهزه دي كلها بتجمع
بيانات طول الوقت وتبعتها للشركات اللي
عامله الاجهزه دي زي مثلا الابل واتش
الساعه بتاعه ابل انا لابسها طول الوقت
فالسؤال من يملك هذه البيانات هل هو
مستخدم الجهاز او هي او الشركه اللي عامله
الجهاز فكره كمان الخوارزميات اللي بتعمل
البريديكشن او بتعمل التنبقات هل دي همم
عادله ولا مش عاجله يعني نقدر نتخيل مثلا
ان معظم
الساعات بتاعه ابل اللي الناس بتشتريها
القادرين بس هم اللي بيقدروا يشتروها في
الاجهزه
ومعروف مثلا ان ان خوارزميات الذكاء
الصناعي
بتتعلم ببيانات اللي بنديها لها للتعلم
فاذا كانت البيانات دي كلها مجمعه من
القادرين هل هل فكره البرسجن او الطب
الدقيق هل هيبقى
ايضا قادر قابل للتطبيق على للفقراء ولا
لا
تحديات الحقيقي هذه نقطه يعني مثيره
للاهتمام يعني اتحول بها الدكتور الحسامي
دكتور وائل يعني هذه الاجهزه كلها همم
يعني مكلفه همم نوعا ما ويتم الحديث عنها
في دول متقدمه ايضا همم تملك جامعه تقوم
بكل هذه الدراسات وهي المسؤوله عن انتاجه
وحتى من الدول غير المتقدمه يجب ان يكون
لديها الامكانيات لشراء هذه التقنيه هذا
يدعون اللي همم السؤال عن المستفيد وعن
المساواه في تعميم همم الفائده على مئات
جايين من المرضى في العالم باعتقادك
اتحدث عن العداله الاجتماعيه في موضوع
الطبي يعني للاسف هو من ناحيه نظريه
التكنولوجيا الاصل انها تساهم في تقليل او
تخفيض التكلفه على المرضى وهذا متوقع
عندما يطلق همم الاقمار الصناعيه الانترنت
وينتشر عن طريق الاقمار الصناعيه في الكره
الارضيه لكن قد يحتاج الى وقت اي تقنيه
وغير يعني سواء كانت تكنولوجيا او غير
تكنولوجيا حتى العلاجات تبدا همم
باسعار مكلفه جدا ومن ثم همم يعني معزه مع
همم حاله انه الشركات ساهمت او تخلت عن
بعض من الملكيه الفكريه قد تساهم في
انتشاره لان نعود يعني لمثل تقريبا
اعتمد على
التكنولوجيا العماره سيطرت عليه الدول
الغنيه بالبدايه وكان مكلف جدا ولم يعطى
لجميع الدول لكن مع الزمن همم اصبح الان
ب- متناول معظم الناس في معظم دول العالم
وليس جميع دول العالم نعم هناك تخوفات ان
هذا هذه تكنولوجيا والعلاج المستخدم
المستخدم بالامكانيه فعلا من همم الحصول
عليها الان اذا كنا لنا نتحدث عن هذه
الاجهزه الى اي مدى سهلت عملكم انتم انتم
اخصائيين وهل من تخوفات بانها يمكن ربما
ان تعوض عن الطبابه العاديه بمفهومها
العادي وبالتالي يقل ربما اللجوء الى همم
الطبيب ام ماذا ام هي مسهلا مكمله كيف
ترونها انتم كاخ اسرائيل
بالعكس انا يعني نراها مكمله لعمل الطبيب
الانسان كائن اجتماعي لا يستطيع ان يعيش
بدون حديث مع الاخرين وفهم المريض من
ناحيه نفسيه ومن ناحيه اجتماعيه
حتى تكمل لكن هذه الاجهزه ساهمت بشكل كبير
في تسهيل عملنا من ناحيه العلاج مثال اخر
اريد ان اعطي للاخر للمشاهدين وللجميع
مرضى هبوط القلب وتجمع السوائل في الرئه
السابق لابد انهم ياتوا الى غرف الطوارئ
وبشكل معاناه من التجمع سوائل في الرئه
وضيق النفس وغيره من ذلك الان بزراعه هذا
الجهاز البسيط جدا همم داخل همم الرئه
نستطيع همم عن بعد التحكم ومعرفه اذا
المريض الان ارتفع عنده ضغط الدم في الرئه
ممكن ان يدخل في حاله سواء بالتالي يتم
الاتصال فيه من مستشفى بزياده همم الليزكس
او الادويه المساعده في التخلص من هذه
السوائل قبل ان يعني ياتي الى المستشفى
فساهمت حسب الدراسات بتقليل زياره همم او
ادخال الى المستشفيات بنسبه 50% فهذه
التكنولوجيا ستساهم وتساعد الاطباء
بالاضافه المرضى طبعا بشكل كبير من ناحيه
كواليتي اوف لايف والحياه همم حياه حياه
تبدو انت يعني ايجابيا فيما يخص هذا
الموضوع ومن المساندين لفكره الانترنت ال-
ال- الاجسام وبانه بالفعل يشكل طفره
ويساعد همم الاخصائيين في مجال الصحي
الدكتور حسام عبد المجيد تحدث عن بعض
الاحاديث وليس لوحده في هذا الموضوع نتوقف
مع بعض المشاركات حول هذه النقطه تحديدا
عن المحاذير والمخاطر لهذه التقنيات ففي
مشاركت معنا الدكتور طارق ابو غزاله رئيس
الاطباء مستشفى
في فرجينيا تحدث عن جانب من محادير اجهزه
انترنت الاجسام التي ترافق
تطورها المتسارع نتابع وجهه نظره
عدسات لاصقه ذكيه ايضا تحدد يعني يعني
تحدد عيار السكر في الدمع تحدد عيار الملح
في الدمع هو كثير من هذه الامور هناك الان
الشبس تتعرف على الشخص تحدد هويه هذا
الشخص بحيث تستخدم في اماكن شركات ذات
سريه كبيره الدخول دون الحاجه الى الى
بطاقه هذه تم زرعها تحت الجلد طبعا هذا
التحديد للهويه قد يكون هناك ايضا فيه
تهديد للهويه كما لاحظنا ان هذه كلها
ترتبط بالواي فاي ترتبط بالانترنت الخارجي
لذلك يستطيع اي هكر الدخول عليها وهمم
تلاعب بالمعلومات هناك همم الكثير الان من
البحث والاموال تنفق في ذلك المجال
لمحاوله همم الاستفاده منها لتحسين حياه
الناس وحياه المرضى بدوره يشدد دكتور عبد
الله الحماقه المدير التنفيذي للجمعيه
القطريه للسكري على ضروره كافه المعلومات
لدى المستشفيات والمراكز الصحيه حتى لا
تتعرض لاختراقات مشيرا الى نقص خبره بعض
الممارسين الصحيين في قطاع تكنولوجيا
انترنت الاجسام ومطالبا بضروره تاهيلهم
على التحول الامثل للمتابعه
انه معظم الممارسين الصحيين ما عندهم
الخبره الكافيه في التعامل مع الامن
الاسبريتو وبالتالي نصحه همم اداره
الاغذيه والادويه الامريكيه بانه لابد من
من
تثقيفهم في كيفيه همم
يعني همم في كيفيه التعامل مثل همم مثل
هذه الاختراقات ايضا في همم مهم جدا ايضا
فيما يتعلق
انه لابد من التحديث الانظمه هذه
وايضا مثلا كثير ان هذه لها لها لها همم
همم فيها على سبيل المثال همم
الدخول الدخول مثل هذه الطلاب الاداره لا
بد ان يكون هناك باسورد يكون الابد هناك
هناك يوزر نيك فهذه المعلومات لا يعني
لابد انه انه الشخص اللي تعامل هذا اللاين
لا يمكن ان ان ينقل مثل هذه المعلومات
لشخص اخر
الكريمين دكتور وائل عبد المجيد تحديدا
كنت قد تحدث ايضا عن بعض المحاضر والمخاطر
وكنت قد تناولت نقطه بان بعض الشركات
والمؤسسات الكبرى همم يكون لديها
الامكانيه للدخول دي همم بيانات ربما
ملايين همم الاشخاص لكن السؤال يعني كيف
يمكن اخضاع هذه الشركات باعتقادك للقوانين
وفرض احترام سريه هذه البيانات من الجهه
المنموطه بها عمل ذلك وفرضه على هذه
المؤسسات او الجهات ايا كانت
اعتقد ان هو اللي بيحصل ده شيء طبيعي جدا
في عاده تاريخيا يعني ايه تكنولوجيا دائما
سابقه مساله القوانين ولكن دلوقتي وصل
الامر لان الكيانات الحكوميه او الكائنات
الديمقراطيه محتاجه انها تعمل تقنين
لكيفيه التعامل الشركات دي مع البيانات هل
البيانات دي زي ما قلت قبل كده هل هي ملك
المستخدم ولا ملك الشركه وهل الشركه من
حقها انها تستخدم البيانات دي على سبيل
المثال مش بس في البرسيشن ميدسين ممكن
يعمله التارتد ادفيتايزنج يعني ممكن
الشركه تبعت لك اعلان على دواء انت ما
كنتيش عايزه تشوفيه قبل كده فالمحتاج
الكائنات الديمقراطيه دلوقت حكومات
والهيئات الحكوميه محتاجه انها تبدا تعمل
تقنين لكيفيه استخدام التكنولوجيا دي او
تعامل الشركات همم من خلال التكنولوجيا دي
مع ال- المستخدم النهائي احد شهود الفيلم
في الواقع الترجمان قال في قصتنا مثلا انه
في امريكا توجد قوانين همم
الى الانترنت وحتى انتهت الاجسام يعني هم
متقدمون عده خطوات عنه سؤال عن منطقه نحن
في العالم العربي في الشرق الاوسط اين نحن
من هذه التشريعات هل بدات تنبه فعليا لهذا
الموضوع ما معلوماتكم في هذا الخصوص
الحقيقه انا باختلف مع الضيف الكريم يعني
هو حتى هنا في امريكا في صحيح في صحيح
رجليشنز لما بيتكلم على فيسبوك ميكر مثلا
او منظم ضربات قلب صحيح الحاجات اللي زي
كده لازم
بتعدي في الاف دي ايه اللي هي منظمه
الادويه والاغذيه ولكن همم في في ما فيش
اي رجوليشنز مثلا في المعلومات اللي
بتجمعها ساعه زي بتاعه ابل واتش مثلا حتى
في حتى هنا في امريكا
القوانين مش متقدمه قوي زي ما الناس
متخيله في الشرق الاوسط الحقيقه المساله
اسوء بكده بشويه لانه همم الكائنات
ديمقراطيه في الشرق الاوسط لسه ما قامتش
بدورها الكافي في مساله تقنين ال- همم
التعامل الشركات الكبيره دي مع البيانات
اللي بتجمعها من الشرح الاوسط فدي الحقيقه
مشكله قبل الحكومات والكائنات الديمقراطيه
عشان اوسط محتاجه تقوم بواجب بواجيبها
ودور اكبر من كده شويه في مساله تقنين همم
الشركات دي او تعامل الشركات دي مع
البيانات اللي بتتجمع من المستخدمين
الدكتور وائل الحسامي اود ان اتحدث معك
ايضا عن بعض المحاذير او المخاطر سميها ما
شئت فيما يتعلق بهذه همم التكنولوجيا
المتطوره بانترنت الاجسام هناك من يتحدث
عن خطورتها ربما كموجات صوتيه يمكن ان
تحدثها هذه الاجهزه اللصقه بجسم الانسان
تماما كما يتم التحضير من اجهزه
الموبايلات وما يمكن ان يكون لها من
سلبيات على همم الانسان وايضا همم هناك
تحضير ايضا من ربما امكانيه حدوث خلل ما
في ما يخص هذا الجهاز مما يمكن ان يمثل
خطرا ايضا على همم المرضى ما رايكم في
اللي مثل هذه التحذيرات وكيف يمكن الاجابه
على هذه التخوف فات علميه
يعني بالبدايه لابد ان نركز على ان هذه
الاجهزه جاءت لانقاذ المرضى يعني بدون هذه
الاجهزه بعض المرضى لن يستطيعون الحياه
وفي اي علاج له اعراض جانبيه فالاجهزه قد
تكون لها اعراض جانبيه لكن اعراضها
الجانبيه في رايي اقل من اعراض الجانبيه
للادويه لانه غير ملموسه للادويه لكن
الاجهزه لطريقه
تتبعها تكنولوجيا نستطيع معرفه الخلل من
ناحيه الاجهزه حتى نعود لموضوع المستشفيات
وخارج المستشفيات الاجهزه التي تستخدم في
القطاعات الطبيه هي منظمه بشكل كبير جدا
وتقضى الى تجارب والى بروسيس طويله فهمم
قليل جدا من الحوادث التي ما ندره حدثت
وتم سحب هذه الاجهزه بشكل مباشر عن طريق
الاف دي ايه حتى ان بعض الاجهزه بعد
زراعتها وهذا حدثت السابق طلب بتغيير
للمرضى على حساب هذه الشركات لاجهزه اخرى
ففي ريكول برانسيس في الولايات المتحده عن
اذا اذا ما حدث وهذه نادره جدا
من ناحيه القوانين الناظم بموضوع
الامور اللي تدخل داخل القطاعات الصحيه
احنا نرى انها منظمه واحيانا بعض الناس
يروا انها همم تنظيم فيها اوبر الجليد همم
هو كما تفضل همم اخي المحاور
الامور التي لا تدخل همم داخل المستشفيات
عن طريق الافلوج واللي بتوصل الذئاب قروب
هاي هاي ما فيها همم قوانين ناضله همم
برده كما حدث في تقرير يعني تحدث تقرير
بعض الولايات فيها همم قوانين همم اكثر من
ولايات اخرى ولايات كاليفورنيا لان فيها
قوانين همم تنظم عمل هذه
ههه الاجهزه وغيرها من الانترنت همم
الولايات المتحده حاول الكونغرس الامريكي
في 2019 تقديم همم قانون شامل لتنظيم هذه
القوانين الا انهم لم يتفقوا على ذلك الان
من يملك هذه المعلومات ودقتها هاي مش
موجوده في الوطن العربي بشكل كبير هي
يملكها الغرب
والتنظيم يبدا بالغرب طبعا الدول العربيه
لا بد انها تحاول تضع همم شروط لهذه
الاجهزه وطريقتها الاجهزه الطبيه المنظمه
في جميع الدول العربيه همم مشابهه ل- همم
الغذاء والدواء الامريكيه لكن نتحدث عن
الانترنت بشكل عام تملك الدول الغربيه
ويبدا همم بشكل عام لابد من هذه الدول
كلها ان تجتمع وتضع تسموها يعني قوانين
ناظيمه عبر الكره الارضيه لانه الانترنت
لا يعرف الحدود ولا يعرف الدول ولا يعرف
الاسماء
نتساء الحقيقه الان ربما عن الافاق
المستقبليه لهذه التكنولوجيا معك الدكتور
وائل الحسامي ابقى معك انا ما الاستخدامات
الطبيه الطبيه اللي هذه التكنولوجيا
التكنولوجيا والى اين يمكن ان تصل الابحاث
في مجال استخدام هذه التكنولوجيا في تعزيز
وفي تعزيز قدرات الجسم البشري باعتقادك
يعني
عندنا الان بتعرف في الاطراف الصناعيه
والاطراف الصناعيه غير همم اعتياديه اللي
هي مرتبطه بشكل الكتروني تلصق مع الطرف
الاخر للجسم همم في نقص طبعا في زراعه
الاعضاء فالان يعني مستقبل سيكون
لتكنولوجيا وهذه ال همم الاشياء همم يعني
مستقبل كبير منها القلب الصناعي همم اللي
بدات تجارب عليه الان اا طبعا هذا سيغير
من مجرى الموضوع الحياه الطبيه في
المستقبل همم في هنالك بيستخدم الشيبه
اللي بيزرعوها في همم
الدماغ واا
زياده قدره الانسان على فهم الامور
وقراءتها المشكله فيها انا ممكن تسجل ما
تقرا في الانترنت او مباشره للجهاز وهو في
تخوف على موضوع السيطره على الانسان وغيره
ولكن هذه تخوفات نظريه للاكل يعني سابقا
الموضوع اللي همم يعني بطريقه انا كطبيب
او قطاع طبي همم باهتم في الموضوع اللي
بيهمني من ناحيه ايجابيه للمريض وكيف
استطيع استخدامه بشكل ايجابي همم على همم
الموضوع همم المجموعات الاي تي والدول
تنظيم ما اعمل به انا فانا لا استطيع انه
همم اضع التخوفات امامي بشكل كبير بطريقه
ان تعطل عملي كطبيب لكن هي تخوفات يعني
موجوده ولا يمكن باي طريقه من الطرق همم
نقرانها وهي تقدم بالفعل يعني همم نوافذ
امل للعديد من المرضى في كل انحاء العالم
وتابعنا قصصا في فيلم الليله لكن رغم ذلك
الدكتور حسام عبد المجيد
ونتحدث عن هذا التخوف هذا الهاجس هناك من
يعرف فيه كانت مؤامره ومبالغه في الموضوع
لكن الى اي مدى اعتقادك يمكن بالفعل ان
نقول ان البشريه تقترب الى عالم تتحكم في
البشر اليات وتطبيقات الذكاء الاصطناعي
سمعنا لما كان يحذر منه ويتحدث عن الدكتور
حسام امكانيه قراءه ال- ال- الافكار دكتور
وائل
وليس لها اي علاقه بالواقع العلمي يعني ما
فيش اي حاجه علميا علميا دلوقت تقول ان ان
الذكاء الصناعي او الروبوتس همم وهتتحكم
في حياه البشر بالعكس انا كمان متفائل جدا
وشايف مساله البرسجن او الطب الدقيق
المساله مهمه جدا وحاجه هتساعد في همم في
حل مشاكل كثير صحيه بالنسبه للبشر خاصه لو
اخذنا في الاعتبار التزاوج ما بين الاجهزه
اللي هي بتاعه الانترنت همم انترنت
الاجسام وتطبيقات الذكاء الصناعيه الحاجات
دي كل الحاجات الاجسام دي عباره عن اجهزه
بتجمع بيانات وهمم
والذكاء الصناعي او اللغه اللوغاريتمات
الذكاء الصناعي بتساعد في مساله الطب
الدقيق فانا مش شايف الحقيقه اي اي حاجه
تخلينا نقلق من فكره السيطره او ان الذكاء
الصناعي هي- هيساهم هيتحكم في حياه البشر
هي المساله بس ان في في محاذير معينه زي
الخصوصيه وزي العداله الاجتماعيه محتاجه
تتحل قبل قبل ما يعني في همم استخدامها
هذه الاجهزه يعني نعود بك اذا الى موضوع
الايجابيات في الولايات المتحده بعض
الدراسات تتحدث بان الطلبه السبعين بالمئه
من الامريكيين يستخدمون اجهزه انترنت همم
الاجسام ماذا عن توقعات بشان المستقبل هذه
التكنولوجيا في منطقتنا العربيه
اعتقد انها هتنتشر بشكل يعني متسرع في في
الدول العربيه باعتبار انه العامل الرئيسي
في استخدام هذه او في اقتناء هذه
التكنولوجيا هو ال ال السعر بتاع
التكنولوجيا القدس بتاع التكنولوجيا دي في
في تناقص يعني طول الوقت وبالتالي الناس
هتبدا تستخدمها اكتر هي الفكره زي ما قلت
لحضرتك قبل كده انه طالما الناس هتبدا
تستخدمها في الشرق الاوسط بشكل اكبر
محتاجين الكائنات الديمقراطيه والحكومات
والهيئات تبدا تعمل تقنين لاستخدام همم
ازاي الناس هتستخدم ازاي الشركات هتتعامل
مع البيانات اللي الناس هت- اللي هتتجمع
من الاجهزه اللي الناس هتستخدمها اشكرك
جزيل الشكر الطبقه طبعا تبقى كل همم
تكنولوجيا سلاح ذو حدين على حسب كيف نحسن
استخدامها او نسيه همم استخدامها
والتشريعات ربما تكون مفيده بالفعل في
تقنين هذا
موضوع لتعظيم الفائده منها على اكبر قدر
ممكن خاصه عندما يتعلق الامر باجهزه تساعد
في تحسين صحه همم البشر اشكر ضيفيه
الكريمين دكتور وائل عبد المجيد استاذ
الذكاء الاصطناعي ومؤسس المختبر الذكاء
البصري وتحليل الوسائط كان معدن معنا من
مدينه بيسبر همم واشكر من مدينه بوسنه
الدكتور وائل فهد الحسين الاخصائي في
امراض القلب والشرايين الاستاذ بجامعه
التعفف والمحاضر في طب الكوارث بجامعه
كتاب حلقتنا هذه من برنامج للقصه بقيا
نعود ونلقاكم باذن الله الاثنين القادم مع
بقيه لقصه جديده السلام عليكم
[موسيقى]